Oppenheimer held its World premiere in
Paris on July 11th and soon after early
thoughts flooded Twitter based on those
early reviews it looks like Nolan has
hit yet another cinematic home run
vulture's bilji Berry called it a
relentlessly paced insanely detailed
intricate historical drama that builds
and builds and builds until Nolan brings
a hammer down in the most astonishing
shattering way the Sunday Times Jonathan
Dean also gave Oppenheimer a glowing
review specifically touting the film's
tension and the acting work of Murphy
Matt Damon Robert Downey Jr and Alden
aaronreich while also giving Murphy High
marks total films Matt matum added the
scale the sound and visuals were
awe-inspiring GQ Francis Adam Sanchez
commented Christopher Nolan wanders in
the mind of Oppenheimer and transforms
the ravages of the past into worries for
the World of Tomorrow Elsa castlesia
variety reported that audiences were so
impacted by the film that they stayed at
the Grand Rex Theater after it ended to
discuss and debater